Juliane starts off this hour in
California hi Julianne how are you I'm
good trying to live the dream love it
how can I help um well I got an
investment broker and I invested two
hundred fifty two thousand into American
funds and I just keep hearing that the
stock market is going to be so volatile
next year I was wondering if I should
keep it in there or take it out did you
invest it for one year or for 20 years
or until I was on 52 and I reinvested it
until I'm 65 sure but I could take it
out it wanted but you're not gonna even
take it out oh when you're 65 you would
just take an income off of it true
okay and so you're going to you're
saying you're investing for 15 or 20
years right thirty years four years
whatever yeah it's not for five years
it's not for one year okay hmm and based
on that you then you found out that the
stock market was is predicted to be
volatile next year yeah I know
stock markets always fall at all well
wouldn't when your investment broker
sends you the letter sends everybody at
saying that you know it's been predicted
that it's going to be extremely volatile
most one of the most that they've seen
that kind of scares me okay well you
ought to call the guy and ask him if
he's suggesting to pull money out of the
stock market because he believes it's
too volatile if he is suggesting that he
should have never put you into a typical
mutual fund and you need a new broker
was it wasn't it was a in the Forbes 500
magazine and then they just the brokers
just sent out the article to all of us I
know why did he send you an article to
scare the crap out of you you know I
don't know I don't either I'm worried
about this guy just let me tell you what
let me tell you what I'm doing with my
mutual fund investments
next year okay nothing okay nothing and
you know how often I read Forbes never
yeah I don't either
yeah because there's a journalism
student with student loan debt that
wrote that article it's not an
investment analyst or an economist and
even if it is a supposed economist
economists are like weather forecasters
they're the only people can be wrong
most of the time and still keep their
jobs so let me tell you what I know
about the American economy I'm 50 a 59
years old come to think of it I need to
remember how old I am and so I'm old I'm
older than you all right here's what I
know about the American economy it goes
up and it goes down but overall
investing into American businesses has
made people wealthy and so I invest in
mutual funds with the mindset that I'm
gonna leave it there for a very long
time and no one gets hurt on a roller
coaster except those that jump off in
the middle of the ride yeah
and I'd be jumping would make you be
jumping based on a rumor from a
journalism student with student loan
debt that writes for Forbes and isn't a
real expert so the difference in me is
I'm not any smarter the only thing I
know is I don't look at the short term
play I always look at the long term play
and you know a group of stocks in the
American Funds which American fund are
you in um well it's American balanced
funds American high income okay you're
in very conservative type mutual funds
then and so you've got some bonds you've
got some some large cap stocks which is
your high income idea there okay now
what that means is you're asking
yourself our companies like General
Motors McDonald's Dell Microsoft 20
years from now then as a group in
general P becomes like that 20 years
from now are they going to be worth more
or less more right if they're not it'd
be the first time in the history of
United
states right that they're not worth more
20 years later regardless of what next
year does so if the journalism student
for Forbes is right and next year is bad
Whoopi I'm not taking it out next year
anyway that's just part of the roller
coaster ride I'm betting on a 20-year
bet I'm not betting on a 12-month bet
right and I think you may need a new
broker a new advisor or someone that
didn't send in your crap in the mail to
scare you I don't know what he's trying
to do was trying to turn your account or
whether he's just a panic person himself
boy I was careful with that okay so yeah
you just need to you need to you need to
have people in your corner that talk you
off the ledge not talk to you onto the
ledge when it comes to long-term
investing that's what I do
personally it's what I do that's what
our smart mr. pros will do if you're not
working with a smart mr. Pro that's
doing that if he's trying to scare you
into short-term investing in a long term
investment because the mutual funds that
you're in or uber conservative you go
back and look go pull out charts up
online on all three of those accounts
all three of those funds and see how
many times in the last 30 years how many
times they've lost money out of a given
year out of a 25 year span you're gonna
find less than five times they've lost
money 20 times they made money five
times they lost money and what's the net
result over the 25 years they made a
bunch of money from 25 years ago to
today way freakin up and that's what
you're betting on because you're only 50
to 20 years from day you'll be 72
twenty-five years 77 and you'll still be
eating off its nest egg this money will
still be invested you'll just be pulling
some of the income off of it and so you
that's the come time horizon you've got
and the funds you're in or not volatile
funds matter of fact they should have a
beta of volatility less than the overall
market with the funds you describe to me
so go back and look at the track records
on them and say how many times I lost 25
years have they lost money and how much
more are they worth now than they were
25 years ago and I think you'll find
that it's very very calm very
komm American Funds has a classical fund
fidelity has Magellan it's the big dog
right fidelity Magellan is a classic
known mutual fund you can go look at it
it's interesting to read the history on
it it's a huge mammoth fund American
Funds has one of the oldest funds out
there it's almost 80 years old called
ICA investment company of America and
you go pull that one up on the internet
I'm not recommending funds but it's just
an interesting study for all of us who
get scared by these idiots in the news I
mean these reporters in the news and so
you look at the ICA and go over almost
80 years how many times has it actually
lost money and how much more is it worth
today than it was 80 years ago that's a
pretty strong track record yeah and it
just kind of gives you a feel for what
the stock market's about on the long
play you should never be invested in
mutual funds on a short play ever under
any circumstances